[Música]
el gobierno de el salvador logró que por
primera vez por segunda vez se
extendiera otro mes el estado de
excepción impulsado por nadie bukele
argumentando su lucha contra la
violencia de las pandillas la asamblea
legislativa aprobó la prórroga da con 67
votos a favor de los 84 que había
posibles si varios así varios derechos
de los salvadoreños siguen interrumpidos
desde finales de marzo cuando entró en
vigor a la medida tras una ola de
violencia que dejó al menos 80 personas
fallecidas a pesar de una baja en la
tasa de homicidios en años recientes el
salvador continúa siendo uno de los
países más violentos del mundo un
fenómeno potenciado por la pobreza y por
la desigualdad
vamos ahora con nuestro invitado del día
el primero de esta mañana es héctor
carrillo director de acceso a la
justicia de fez paz héctor es gracias a
usted puede estar con nosotros y poco
después de asumir la presidencia en 2019
bukele lanzó el llamado plan de control
territorial para desmantelar las
pandillas una iniciativa que todavía no
ha sido publicada completamente y que ha
sido criticada por no ser eficiente es
por ello que busque el está usando el
estado de emergencia y lo mantiene
renovado
muy buenos días un saludo a todas las
personas que nos siguen en diferentes
partes del mundo a través de este medio
de comunicación desde la fundación de
estudios para la aplicación del derecho
fespad a pues es un honor poder
participar en este espacio en efecto
la aprobación del régimen de excepción
ya de manera consecutiva es prueba del
fracaso del plan control territorial al
que ha hecho alusión constantemente el
gobierno de la república y que no ha
sido no se ha dado a conocer a pesar que
incluso la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos en diciembre de 2019
esto al gobierno para conocer este plan
control territorial es decir que diese a
conocer por lo menos los componentes
teóricos que iban a orientar su
aplicación y los mecanismos de medición
de la efectividad del plan no pero
situaciones como las que se presentó en
marzo donde abruptamente
se incrementaron los homicidios a estas
cifras inéditas en el salvador son
muestras de el fracaso del plan control
territorial es decir que la reducción de
homicidios
aparentemente no era producto de la
efectividad del plan control territorial
y esto se traduce en algo que
reiteradamente hemos señalado como
institución la inexistencia en el
salvador de una política pública en
materia de seguridad
discúlpeme que lo interrumpa porque
quisiera que avanzáramos con más
preguntas
a veces adicional a esta debilidad
institucional y aún hay historiales de
pobreza y de violencia que tiene el país
pues ahora tenemos este nuevo decreto
que suspendió derechos esenciales que se
garantizan en la constitución y que
garantizan por ejemplo el derecho al
debido proceso a la defensa legal el
derecho a la reunión en esas condiciones
las últimas noticias es que son que la
policía detuvo a siete sindicalistas que
habían criticado ya fuera en privado o
en público al gobierno de buques que se
sabe de eso
bueno varias cosas sobre el régimen 1 el
régimen ha sido aprobado sin respetar
los parámetros constitucionales para el
uso de esta herramienta en efecto a una
herramienta de índole constitucional
pero hay parámetros específicos
pasan por relacionar la situación de
emergencia con la supresión de ciertos
derechos ese análisis no se hizo a la
hora de prolongar el régimen y tampoco
se hizo en la primera ocasión en que el
régimen aprobado y la aplicación del
régimen al final la suspensión se ha
traducido en múltiples detenciones de
personas que no están vinculadas a
ningún hecho delictivo no son constantes
las denuncias en medios de comunicación
y algunas organizaciones también que
hemos estado registrando casos de
personas que no tienen relación con
hechos delictivos y sin embargo han sido
y capturadas pero también y esto es
grave las personas que están siendo
sometidas a los procesos no cuentan con
un derecho o una defensa técnica
efectiva en los abogados están
defendiendo a las personas capturadas
son abogados de oficio de la
procuraduría general de la república que
se están haciendo auténticas diez ya
masivas donde los jueces y las cuestas
no están valorando cada caso sino que
casi de manera automática están pasando
a la detención provisional de las
personas mire estamos hablando de más de
30 mil personas heridas entre las que
están como usted mencionó el dirigencia
sindical bueno me queda debiendo más
información sobre los líderes sindicales
pero entonces sigamos por esa línea es
llenar las cárceles la solución qué
efecto se tendría una mayor sobrecarga
sobre carga penitenciaria en el mediano
y también en el largo plazo
el salvador hasta antes de la aplicación
del régimen de excepción ya tenía un
poco más del 136 por ciento de
hacinamiento en sus cárceles
contábamos con una población
penitenciaria de alrededor de 40.000
personas
una cifra que ha crecido abruptamente en
los últimos 20 años allá por el año 2000
contábamos con apenas 7 mil 800 personas
privadas de libertad
este año hasta antes del régimen
teníamos alrededor de 40.000 a esto
habría que sumarle las más de 30 mil
personas que han sido capturadas y esto
nos lleva a un inevitable colapso del
sistema penitenciario en el salvador
donde por cierto ya se han registrado
más de alrededor de 11 muertes de
personas que fueron capturadas durante
el régimen que estaban bajo custodia del
estado y que al muerto el interior de
los centros penitenciarios
héctor como ya nos vemos quedando sin
bien pues le quiero hacer la última
pregunta disculpe que nuevamente lo
tengo que interrumpir la violencia de
pandillas es evidente es una realidad
usted lo ha descrito a lo largo de esta
entrevista y también nos ha hecho ver
que para usted pues no es un plan
efectivo el que está llevando a cabo o
que le qué salida tiene el salvador si
no es esta medida punitiva para combatir
estos problemas estructurales que
conducen a la violencia
lo que sucede es que este tipo de
medidas ya se han aplicado en el pasado
y no han resuelto la problemática en las
cárceles de el salvador el 52% de la
población penitenciaria está relacionado
con el tema de pandillas y sin embargo
esas capas se han hecho estas capturas
masivas durante 20 años y sin embargo al
afuera de los centros penitenciarios las
pandillas siguen teniendo presencia el
presidente busque le hablaba de
alrededor de 70.000 miembros de
pandillas quiere decir que no basta con
la captura no es la única salida ni la
más efectiva se necesita medidas
integrales que pasen por cambiar la
realidad de las personas en todo el
territorio del salvador el salvador-
tiene apenas el 15 por ciento de su
población que tiene más de 13 años de
escolaridad es decir hay una ausencia
del estado en materia de educación en
las cárceles el 97 por ciento de las
personas que están en las cárceles nunca
pudieron llegar a la universidad y
alrededor del 93 por ciento ni siquiera
curso educación media bachillerato
entonces problemas estructurales como
ese son los que hay que resolver para
cambiar la realidad de los territorios y
evitar que las pandillas sigan creciendo
obviamente el tema represivo es
necesario para las personas que han
cometido un hecho delictivo pero no
puede ser la medida prioritaria ni la
única y tampoco llevarse de encuentros
personas que no están involucradas en
hechos delictivos ver